guten morgen alle miteinander ich hoffe
hatte bisher einen wohl auf hold an wer
ruft mich jetzt an kennen wir diese
leute die euch anrufen und die ruft eine
sekunde später zurück und bangen
wie geht einfach nicht dran warum ich
muss mich auf jeden fall mal die zähne
wir hoffen deshalb marien und bloß nicht
ankommen eindeutig war dann doch hier
war früher ins und väter spinnen
wie geht's dir so ich gehe zum friseur
ich bin eigentlich komplett standard
lukas schmitz mal wieder geworden also
an den seiten irgendwie 67 mm open ist
etwas abgeschnitten
ich würde zu freunden vom hauptbahnhof
ab und dann fahren wir nach münster
wir sind in münster angekommen an der
fom hochschule hof parken aber jetzt
fahren wir zusammen nach ibbenbüren
sowie es übrigens auch mit am start dass
ich zeige euch nach tokio gehen wir hin
einkaufen was kaufen ein wasser wasser
die 61 wenn du ein problem zwischen
viersen und münchen
[Musik]
gesunde ernährung wird ganz groß
geschrieben
das gab es schon dunkel draußen ich habe
irgendwie die letzten zwei drei stunden
gar nichts mehr gefilmt wir gehen das
auf jeden fall auch mit ihrem ist
vielleicht fühle mich dass das was von
der civis wir gehen jetzt geben dass
aura oder wir sind jetzt wieder hier zu
hause angekommen bei einem kollegen in
ibbenbüren wer kennt es nicht hinter
würde ich sagen tobi hat die letzten
worte für den heutigen tag und zwar tor
alles klar wir gehen jetzt auf jeden
fall nennen
tropez schon nicht mehr auf dem boden
und ich würde sagen dass ich kann
und damit herzlich willkommen hier heute
zu einem neuen tag ich bin hart fertig
ist auf jeden fall erstmal duschen ist
einen ganzen tag hat er keinen orte lang
wir sind jetzt erst mal am frühstücken
[Musik]
tobi ist nun auf einbrüche kanada oder
hast ne schau auf jeden fall an pascals
mutter dafür dass wir uns dieses
frühstück hier gezaubert hat ist auf
jeden fall teil der doku die packen
jetzt unsere sachen und fahren dann nach
hause
[Gelächter]
tobias werden uns jetzt nach hause und
ich schlafe auf dem beifahrersitz weiter
man hat von hier ein überblick ne danke
fürs fahren
wir sehen uns auch ein
hey wir sitzen wieder bei mir im auto
und fahren jetzt zum zu mir ich bin
wieder zu hause angekommen noch mal ganz
kurz entschuldigungen das gestern abend
irgendwie nicht so richtig eine upload
gemacht habe sage ich mal dass ich heute
morgen nicht diese typische szene
gemacht haben wie ich im bett liege und
der wecker klingelt und so irgendwann
halt bei einem kumpel und barendorf
lackieren muss man machen gefällt und
dann fand ich das so ein bisschen in der
pro trade den ich habe da irgendwas auf
kanalinseln auf jeden fall meint voll
viele unter dem blog von von zwei tagen
das fluggerät in dem blog firefall kurz
dass ich das halt einige ein bisschen
länger gewünscht haben würde ich sagen
hey machen wir einfach heute noch mal
luca reagiert
ich wollte eigentlich mit dem ersten
video anfangen aber dann war ich
ziemlich fertig zum beispiel irgendwann
kommt ihre lady lay flug aber jetzt
fangen wir an mit dem ersten video wie
kann es sein dass du dreimal am tag oder
so duschen geht es aber immer noch
stinkt waren ist klar dankeschön für
diese motivierende dankeschön auf jeden
fall also zunächst aber muss ich sagen
die kameraführung ist einsame spitze man
sieht einfach nicht höchste den kopf dem
versteht man ich mich richtig also ton
ist jetzt auch nicht so das beste aber
ich würde sagen ich bin ein bisschen
vorn schauen was jedoch so passiert wenn
man an der stelle muss ich jetzt
wirklich mal anmerken beschweren kann
ich mich da normalerweise eher weniger
[Musik]
bei solchen fragen die flächen kontext
das ist irgendwie gerissen wurde da saß
ich genau wie und habe einen karton
genommen voraussage schaut weil da jetzt
noch hin und wieder einmal hinten
geschmissen weil ich ging was braucht
was ich ein wegschmeißen konzert sorry
da geht das den karton war huub stevens
meinte sippel das sind alpakas
die mittel sind blödsinn jetzt mal ganz
kurze sache und zwar wie hat sich das
alles eigentlich mit den alpakas
entwickelt immer wenn ich fantreffen
mache ist das haupt ding was ich neben
pizza sachen geschenkt bekomme wie
irgendwelche alter stofftiere t shirts
ein paar socken auf der wolle
irgendwelche bilder davon uns
ich weiß das ist meine lieblingstiere
sind aber das sage ich noch nicht so
häufig das ist so krass fiel von euch
dahingehend gibt oder ob ich gegen einen
baum
wir haben einen kleinen komischen junge
der springt die hitze relevante also ich
mir schon so ban
das ist einfach meine community ist es
die luxus ist es die partie doch nicht
so springt der vormaligen der band der
ja was bist du bitte für ein mensch also
ich weiß nicht was du beiden community
von anderen usern so abgeht ich meinen
bei mir springen die ganz gerne mal den
kleiderschränken und auch gegen
kleiderschränke
daumen hoch wäre ja auch einer luke
rusal christian anleger da muss man am
ende auf jeden fall noch mal brachte
beleidigen der ist schuld daran dass die
zweimal gegen schreib gesprungen ist bei
diesen videos in der typ einfach den
arsch von einem schaf waren ganz schön
scharf
[Musik]
soundcloud laser luca neues mixtape habe
ich da heute hochgeladen link ist in der
beschreibung genau an der stelle würde
ich jetzt allerdings auf druck reagiert
für heute beenden ja ich weiß die trauer
ist gross zu mir leid dass ich ein
bisschen fertig aussehen aber wer mal
letzten acht ein bisschen wenig getrennt
und ich habe jetzt gerade hier noch mal
bei mir im bett anhalt stunden
geschlafen und wieso fühlt er sich
eigentlich nach mittagsschlaf total
verquatscht alle leute lover von wegen
power nap und bleibe möglich das einfach
nicht
ich bin dann auch noch viele bekloppte
als vorher auf jeden fall frage ich
jetzt mal meine mum ob in essen geplant
ist welcher partner ist irgendwas in
essen geplant haben
wo haben wir salz denn die allgemeine
linse beschlägt ich könnte schon wieder
schlafen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hmm
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich finds halt einfach übels neues
dadurch dass ich jetzt mein studium
beendet hat habe ich halt mehr zeit wir
solche sachen beizubringen habe ich
glaube ich schon 1000 neue gesagt dass
ich das feuer auf jeden fall geht es
erst mal die zähne putzen
in der tat weh tut es irgendwie voll
leid ist seit gestern unter blog heute
so richtig dumm worden
der blog wird auf jeden fall meister
spannender da werde ich zurück nach köln
fahren paar andere sachen werden
passieren wenn euch dieser blog ja heute
allerdings trotzdem gefallen dann will
ich mich sehr darüber einen like von
euch freuen weil sie noch keiner denn
von einem kanal sein was sehr kaka ist
könnt ihr unter dem video einfach auch
abonieren klicken da verpasste keine
videos mehr und wenn ich schon abonnent
sind könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken
denn dann bekommt ihr benachrichtigungen
wenn ich ein neues video hochladen sonst
würde ich den blog jetzt allerdings auch
an dieser stelle hier beenden wenn ihr
im nächsten block in die neue luca
kommentiert kommentare folgen kommt gold
dann schreibt einfach unten das war eng
bleibt einfach hier unter dem video
irgendein kommentar irgendein würzigen
frage keine ahnung war sonst würde ich
ja noch einen schönen tag und wir sie
nur den nächsten block übermorgen
[Musik]